mein kopf tut echt so vene wenn diese
ganze steuerbar ist
es ist einfach nur krank es tut einfach
nur weh ich finde einfach mal mitmachen
und mir dann so eine challenge machen
hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen folge challenge accepted und
zwar wurde mir jetzt bezüglich 1.7
geschrieben dass ich mal als challenge
machen soll
super secret settings ihr seht es hier
kann man die einstellen
dann hat man immer einen anderen effekte
minecraft könnte man machen wenn ihnen
etwas besseren pc hat man das ist nicht
allzu gut und mein gott ist das komisch
und zwar musste ich auf dem kopf stehen
und ein wenn ich so mache ich kann mich
gar nicht so kopf stellen es geht ja
auch vor allem im kopf hat geklappt
ich muss ein haus bauen ich muss ein
haus bauen wie ein williger dorf erwin
villiger haus und ich bin natürlich im
creative und so wenn ich mir die sachen
und zusammen sammeln müsste hatte das
fertig und zwar ich kann ja nicht mal so
ein vernünftiges haus bonn
jetzt muss das hier so machen und das
alles hier so ein war das ist so komisch
diese ganzen blöcke aus zu treffen erst
mal so die blöcke habe ich erstmal die
brauche oder warte ich geh mal in dieses
gebäude seien also ohne witz sage ich
aber jedem change accepted bevor sich
einer beschwert macht erstmal selber
weil sonst hätte die sicht genommen wenn
es nicht schwer sei und ich glaube ich
hätte nach so kopfschmerzen haben keine
tür broich auch noch so eine tür
ich will jetzt rein gehen so dass erde
drin habe ich auch noch erde und und das
gras mache ich auch so so gehe ich
wieder raus weil ja noch einen schönen
weg dahin und das bei euch das denn hin
das ist echt so komisch ich kannte ja
mal ne ich werde euch das nicht umdrehen
weil sonst werden einige sagen je
nachdem kann zeit komisch gespielt ihr
werdet genau die gleichen bedingungen
haben mich aber ist es so komme ich
zurück ich guck mal eben von oben von
oben geht sogar noch von oben ist ja
ganz egal
ok ich werde das haus wobei ich das denn
hin bauen ich werde das jahr hierhin
bauen wollte war diese steuerung ist ja
auch invertiert sehen dass hier hin
hier ist sogar schon weg dann kann ich
mir das mit dem weg ja sparen so und
zwar erwarte ich glaube ich war eine
treppe bräuchte treppe ist so crazy
ich hätte bauchschmerzen bauchschmerzen
zu kopfschmerzen haben sie geben immer
die treppe hier ich bekommen denn schon
bei ich jetzt oben drauf auch noch so
was mit zaun war das denn jetzt da war
das hier hin nein nein nein nein
so hätte meine maus ist auch so weit vom
bildschirm schon wieder weg das ist so
krass ihr könnt mir challenges wieder
die kommentare schreiben dies dass ich
machen soll
so leute los geht's hier kommt erstmal
blocking falsch ich muss sehr hoch
fliegen damit die so richtig sind so
reich dass gerade richtig so ich habe
mir nach vorne ohne falsch dem den boden
aus diesem komischen steinchen so wie
breit haben die das 5 breit ich mach das
einfach mal nur so als beispiel
sein wille dorf so und zwar ich muss es
im stehen machen ja ne ist das ja nicht
cool
das bin ich ja kein sie eigentlich doch
die hoch singen einfach 2345 kommen
jetzt geht es noch mal hierhin so ich
kann jetzt schon kopfschmerzen
ich glaub ich muss auch kurzen 4 zurück
bisschen
nein es ist echt so krank ist jetzt ca
dann habe ich doch noch sechs lang
gebaut gebaut
es ist so komisch ist es so komisch dass
die ganze steuerung einfach investiert
ist das ist so krank um ein stück nach
hinten so ok ich hab' die grundfläche
und ich bin grad schon drei minuten am
aufnahme ist so krank
okay die grundfläche ist da wie bauen
die das da hinten
die haben jetzt auf jeden fall erstmal
drei an den seiten hoch ich muss hier
auf 1 2 so hier auch nein kommen so
12 bei mir so krass am regnen 1 28 die
taktik nein auch falsche richtung
ich vergesse dass investiert ist boah
ist das heftig häufig das den kopf wäre
so halten 1 812 so ihr kommt da weg ihr
seid nicht doof vorne mache ich auch mal
eben weg machte das hier so das
grundgerüst steht 99 so kommt mein fuß
juckt mich passt mein fuß ist kann ich
gerade mein fokus ist gut einen
mückenstich er ist kann ich seinerzeit
mit mir steht ich habe mit dem winter so
lukat mückenstich was los ok jetzt
kleide ich das mit den wurden plans aus
scheiße ich bin ja gar nicht wie ich das
überhaupt richtig
eigentlich müsste doch das warte ich
flieg mal kurz nach vorne vielleicht
komplett falsche richtung erstmal nein
nein nein da hin und zwar ach die sind
von da an noch mal drei hoch die ich
hier nicht die hier sind da doch auch
von da an drei hoch möchte so einzubauen
da muss ich diese ganzen komischen teile
hier nochmal einen höher setzen
nein daraus ein 23 das ist das hier so
und da kommt noch ein blog in 23
daher so einen satz habe ich aber im
lauf jungs so scheiße doch nicht dachte
ich hätte das system verstanden aber nur
halbwegs
ich mache das steuer nicht mehr mit wie
ok ich habe kein schüler mit dem
gesteuert so dass heißt hier kommen noch
einer hinunter commander drauf und da
und da und hier noch einer war mein kopf
tut nicht so weh weil diese ganzen
steuerbar ist ruhig es ist einfach nur
krank es tut einfach nur weh ich könnte
einfach mal mitmachen und mir dann so
eine challenge machen
zu dem video antworten change accepted
video antwort luca es ist falsch
so kommst du noch weg kommst nämlich
daran so das steht allerdings muss der
weg dass das der weg zu da kommt nämlich
jetzt tür und treppe scheiße und hier
noch dings und er hat ja erde als boden
jetzt wenn ich warum die auf erde wohnen
aber gut bei ihnen auf jeden fall dann
noch und da und da waren jetzt so ein
bisschen hiervon drauf so mache ich hier
noch einen mach ich da noch eine hin
da kommt jetzt die tolle tür rein so die
tür steht alter okay jetzt kommt hier
das rein da kommt noch ein fenster rein
also so langsam begreife ich sie alles
so ein bisschen wie sie das da hinten
jetzt aus auch jetzt ist jetzt kommen
diese teile hier drauf hopp hopp hopp
hopp hopp hopp hopp hopp hopp hopp hopp
hopp hat jetzt muss dann immer ganz
kurzen fliegen wie das tier jetzt
aussieht aber das ohne leiter auch noch
scheiße den leiter bei euch auch noch
warte die gleich mit mehr leben wie ich
jetzt drauf scheiße eine leiter bräuchte
ich glaube jetzt sogar vernünftigen
boden hier oder hier oder sogar
steinboden den ich machen wollte
durch wollte am anfang eigentlich in
anderen machen den ich jetzt machen
wollte egal ob eine mischung aus den
wörtern sonntag boden halt nie kommen
menschen machen wir zu sehen da wird
schon mal dem beispiel machen wir sehen
auch
so cobblestone hier noch ein hin da noch
einen hin
hoppe nein und ob und jetzt kommt die
leiter ich mache die leiter mal scheiße
wusstet ihr dass die tür
ok nachdenken wenn da die tür ist da
reinkommen wollte ich leiter hier machen
jetzt kommt da als ablage auch
wiederholen plenk das heißt da da da da
tut doch irgendwie weh ich weiß nicht ob
das daran liegt dass ich hier die ganze
zeit so komisch gucke hält das ist
dieser secret settings mehr wer macht
dann bitte so ein scheiß
jetzt mache ich hier den zaun drum das
ist ich hasse das wenn man so
kleinlicher arbeit macht ich hasse
kleinlicher arbeit ohne witz ich könnte
nie so nickel und dann so zwei jahre
daran lässt sondern doofen decke oder
irgendwie sowas oder zwei wochen zwei es
vielleicht ein bisschen hoch gegriffen
ich glaube ich hab's ich glaube das
war's oder das von willemer häuschen ich
mir das mal so von dings angucken
ja ich glaube das war's als ich am einen
kompletten tag und nachtrhythmus
gebraucht ich mir jetzt noch eben hier
stellt euch mal vor das inventar wer
noch alles auf den kopf
ich stelle jetzt noch eben eine fackel
in die mitte so und jetzt mach ich das
mal wieder aus kombiniert man diese ist
das schön so alles so zu machen
so eine runde survival games spielen
alter dass wir auch heftig somit super
secret settings kommen hatten wir so als
kameramann
ja meine damen und herren gelegen was
schönes haus häufig gerade gebaut haben
auf dem kopf trägt auf jeden fall
wunderschönen aus ich habe zwar totaler
kopfschmerzen
aber sind wir bei mtv cribs wir können
das auch selber zeigen mit mtv cribs
borders für geil ich gehe also hin
sondern meine damen und herren wir
wieder bei mtv cribs wir schauen hier
wieder so ein gebäude an
ja richtig geil wunderschön so viel gut
gemacht hier in das gebäude
superschön gebaut das ist ein cooles
secret okay das ist scheiße ich will
wieder zurück auf meine nummer das ist
sehr sehr pixelig alte das ist so dass
es so horror mäßig das ist nicht so
komplett schwarz weiß wenn man sie trotz
moz was grün ist aber es ist auf jeden
fall die sättigung rausgenommen
das ist so für horror sachen ganz gut
also an sich sind die shader ganz klar
mein gott das ist alles verschwommen
sollte wäre ich hacke das ist
oh mein gott wirklich offener drogen
oder so was dass das ist so ein blöder
das hier ist so ein bisschen wässrig das
normal
ja das normal dass gut ok freude dass
das haus fertig gebaut habe sich auf
jeden fall natürlich aus eigentlich ich
find's ganz natürlich sagen es euch
gefallen hatten die magic expected haben
wollt dann accepted haben wollt gibt
einen daumen nach oben das würde mich
auf jeden fall freuen uns ist nur einen
klick
also von daher könnt ihr euch da ruhig
noch ein bisschen finger sport betreiben
und ihr könnt auch weiterhin challenges
in die kommentare schreiben nicht an
beim nächsten mal machen soll und dann
will ich sagen demnächst mal wieder rein
meine lieben freunde und